the document covers a total of 288
points and lays out the views of a pope
who said from the start that the
catholic church needs renewal but
Francis also added that he's open to
advice on how his own role should change
since being elected to the papacy back
in March Francis has made a point of
avoiding extravagance and emphasizing
his duty to help the poor he's won
praise for treating others as equals
buona sera his manifesto says the
church's first task is to fight social
ills Francis says a church that's dirty
and bruised from Street work is better
than one preoccupied with the status quo
he says women and young people should
have more say in church affairs but
Francis ruled out discussion over
admitting women to the priesthood and he
remains strictly opposed to abortion the
Pope has shown he's not afraid of
confronting people on sensitive issues
like the treatment of migrants which he
underscored by visiting a refugee camp
the reform process he set in motion will
likely last year's the conference of
German Bishops has welcomed the document
saying it shows the church how to embark
on a new beginning